on crystal this business teachable for
250 million dollars at the age of 29
years old and what's incredible is that
this wasn't just a one hit wonder his
track record goes all the way back to
when he was a teenager making up to a
hundred thousand dollars in a single day
building Facebook apps today we're
getting the blueprint to his success why
he cashed out and how you can get
started creating the next big business
on today's episode of subscribe because
we're closing in on 400 000 subscribers
it would mean a lot to us and uh hey you
know what these are totally free it's
totally free to do but first we're gonna
think today sponsors stream yard and
here's the thing in the last episode
that we did I dared you guys I said that
if you're not signing up for stream yard
let me know what I have to do to get you
to sign up for stream yard and we got a
few comments okay one of them said I
dare Jack interview Graham for a podcast
and I'll get stream yards oh what's your
favorite color I love Chrome Orange
that's oh okay okay sure I will
subscribe to stream yard if Graham gets
me a date with my favorite supermodel he
could even broadcast it so first of all
we gotta know who your favorite
supermodel is so comment back let me
know who your favorite supermodel is I
will DM her and I will see if she will
go on a date with you so that you will
sign up we need your Instagram too
though stream yard is live streaming
Studio platform that's perfect for
creators who want to start making
content on a budget all you got to do
with stream yard is turn on the camera
and start making the content that you
want to make and they will take care of
the rest you can create high quality
content right from your browser and
stream directly to Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn along with many other platforms
they also make it simple to brand and
customize your videos before you even go
live a huge perk that I found is that
you can actually multi-stream so you can
stream to all of your favorite platforms
all at once just expanding your reach
for free think about it if you're making
content for YouTube live you may as well
be on Twitch and Facebook and every
other streaming service at the same time
so start making professional looking
live stream videos with stream yard for
free today with the link Down Below in
the description and again if you're on
the fence about it you can always dare
us to do something so let us know what
we could do for you again down below in
the comments thank you so so much try it
out today and now with it said let's get
back to the podcast what's up guys
welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is Encore knockball I am I was the
founder of teachable and now I'm the
founder of Ocho uh we're here to help
business owners build wealth thank you
so much for doing this man thanks for
having me this is my first time in
Brooklyn in quite a long time and I'm
shocked how like trendy everyone is I
was telling Alex on the way here like
everyone is under the age of 35. they're
really fashionable there's no children
or old people here my parents when they
were visiting there they found no one
within 20 or 30 years of their age
everyone here is I would say between 20
and 30 childless and yeah that's that's
the Bible
yeah yeah yeah this is cool it's my
first time in New York yeah it's well
crazy here I love New York this is so
much fun yeah so tell us a bit of your
uh your background and how you got
started yeah absolutely so uh I'm a
first generation immigrant I moved I
grew up in Oman in the Middle East after
being born in India so it was a very
third culture sort of life because
you're Indian yet I've never lived in
India grew up in the Middle East and
then moved to America for college uh
into California and yeah it was a very
sort of interesting journey to America
but very very grateful to be here tell
us about your your entrepreneurial
Journey where did that start I think for
a lot of people and I was one of them
even ever since I was eight or nine
years old you always try to come up with
these silly little business ideas like I
think the first business idea I had is I
would tear out posters from a magazine
and sell it to my parents friends and
some of them were nice and humored me
and actually bought it
um all the way to a website I designed
with my brother I think it's probably
age 11 or 12. um it was like a web
portal where you could go log on get
news all of that stuff never quite
launched it but it got me started you
know realizing I wanted to be an
entrepreneur of some kind
um I still remember even then my brother
was traumatized but I ended up hiring
him as one of my employees I think I was
like 12 or 13 and he was three years
younger than me he gave him one percent
of equity and every time he didn't
actually work I would fire him and you
know take away his one percent of equity
who go crying to my parents yeah he
would cry to my parents being like I've
lost my one percent or whatever I had to
give it back to him but yeah so I've
always sort of had the makings of that
um before formally taking a plunge but
how are you thinking about that like one
percent equity at the age of like 12 or
13 like where does that come from well I
probably didn't even know the word
Equity I just gave him one percent which
was kind of mean right you would give
him 10 20 yeah one percent is kind of
yeah yeah I think it's a combination of
like older brother bullying as well like
a little bit of that thrown in uh but it
properly took the dive into like
building a business I think my freshman
year of college uh it was the summer of
2007. uh Facebook had just launched the
Facebook app platform and I ended up
building a couple of Facebook
applications and by the end of that
summer I started making 10 or 20 dollars
a day and that was completely
life-changing to realize that you could
do something on the Internet yeah and
earn a living it was like you know a
light bulb went off and since then I you
know I've been building different types
of businesses yeah where were you at
College I was a college in California
Berkeley Berkeley yeah and that summer
specifically I was interning at Amazon
in Seattle I was 18 years old first year
first year first 18 years old interning
in Seattle as a software engineer I
didn't know what I was doing
um did not like my team or co-workers I
had no idea what was happening right I
felt too it was too early for the real
world in a lot of ways and and it
coincided with this time when you know I
had all this time in Seattle and I
started you know building Facebook
applications and yeah it was a good time
you ever have a job before doing all of
this like any sort of you know summer
jobs or anything you Dove straight at
first so that's what's interesting is
growing up in Oman in the Middle East
there's no culture of like children
working you don't actually work until
you have a job but my freshman my
freshman year of college I was working
at a gym very briefly like helping them
with their systems or whatever that was
like one sort of hourly job but even
that was in college got it I'm always
curious because you said you went to
Berkeley so it means you must have been
pretty academic in high school do you
think that like there's a relationship
between people being extremely academic
and then starting startups or do you
think that they're inversely related or
I think I mean I think there's some kind
of relationship but just to be clear I
did get into Berkeley but I got rejected
from my other nine top schools I think I
was I had a really good SAT score but
like my academic grades were what let me
down when you sort of looked at my
college application because I played
sport internationally I had great SATs
my my high school grades were really bad
that was like the one reason really bad
I think it was I don't know I think like
they were really good until like 7th or
eighth grade and then you know you get
distracted by life and trying to be cool
and all this other stuff and not really
studying much and all of that but I
would find bad though because I know
some parents would be like yeah
fair I would say let's say there were
like 30 people in the class 35 and like
or one of my classes I would be like you
know number 10 or 12 or whatever which
is not I still got into Berkeley yeah
but good SAT scores I see I had a
perfect 800 in math and a 700 in English
and for my application English was my
second language it wasn't really but you
know I grew up I grew up Indian and
stuff so it was a 1500 which was happy
with that's good if anything I think
like being good at school probably
slightly correlates with you know being
good at starting a business but not too
much because you sort of have to be a
rule breaker a little bit and kind of
defy authority I think if you want to be
an entrepreneur which doesn't which when
you think about the kids that were best
at school they were the ones who saw an
authority figure and you know sort of
followed it so I think you kind of want
to have a balance of being smart but
also you know disrespecting Authority a
little bit if you want to want to start
something yeah I feel like there's
something there where you're bad at
school and you do really well on the SAT
it just shows like I feel like that's a
pretty good like couple of things that
occur that shows pretty high raw just
intelligence yeah which I feel like also
is probably pretty I feel like for
instance I always did better on tests
like a lot of people do worse on tasks
for me like I typically would do better
in an actual test versus a practice test
for whatever reason so like I always
feel like the pressure is actually
something I enjoy and I do better at how
do you get accepted by Amazon what led
to that I had an interview in college
um I thought I bombed my interview
that's because I he asked me three
questions and I got all of them I didn't
find the correct answer but what you do
is you talk out loud right it was like
solving a programming problem and you
just explain your thought process out
loud but I left the interview telling my
parents being like yeah there's no way
this is happening like I bombed it but
no uh they actually they yeah they gave
me an offer what are the questions I
can't remember it's like a programming
puzzle that you have to solve and you
know I walked him through but I never
came to the solution uh but it kind of
blows my mind even the summer I actually
worked there I didn't do much work at
all in fact I can and see I did anything
yet they invited me back for the second
Summers I think it's also the systems
you know the end of the day they have to
hire so many software Engineers that
once you make it into a big company at
some level you're there by default and
it was very disheartening as well
because while I was at this big company
my entire team was working on a single
page off the Amazon app like it was a
manager inventory page on Seller Central
my entire team's purpose was this one
page and that was very disillusioning
right like that was the first taste of
like what it feels like to be a cog in a
machine where your entire team just
works on one single page
um so yeah I think that's that's about
as far as I've gotten to working at a
large company doesn't it seem highly
inefficient to do something like that
couldn't one person do that like a day
or two that's what I would believe right
I mean I think it's like the assembly
line right like workers had a greater
sense of job satisfaction when they
built something from scratch but then
you introduce the assembly line where
everyone's job was just this one very
specific thing and it made people
unhappy happy I think it was the same
thing at large companies you just
subdivide what people are working on to
such a small Silo that I yeah kind of
was Soul crushing and so you think that
actually negatively affects happiness
when somebody has like one Soul Focus
within a like a like you were explaining
a cognitive machine or like yep exactly
like I think I think that there was
research on this I mean uh where if a
worker creates something from scratch
there's a sense of accomplishment but if
all you're doing is pushing One Nail in
so your entire team is creating
something you lose that sense of
accomplishment you're just yeah you're
just doing a very very siled task and
can you say what they were paying you at
the internship yeah they were paying me
fifty five hundred dollars a month wow
yeah
that was crazy no way yeah that was that
how long ago was that that was 2007.
yeah College that's that's like what you
could graduate kind of yeah and be like
a good job yeah but you know what the
twenty dollars a day I was making doing
things on the internet was so much more
exciting than that because the fact that
I could sit behind my computer do stuff
and get money was it was a light bulb I
mean that basically made me unemployable
after that like yeah so how did you see
Facebook as the next opportunity for
that so I was in Amazon I was 18 years
old I didn't have a fake ID I didn't
know anyone I couldn't do anything for
fun
um I spent my you know I spent my
weekends and nights just had all this
free time I had a Facebook account at
the time as a freshman in college and
you could for the first time build
Facebook applications growing up I was a
huge cricket fan which not a lot of
people know over here but I played
internationally that was my like
Obsession so I built a fantasy Cricket
app for Facebook over the course of that
summer and I didn't know how to code
super well but through that summer I
kind of taught myself everything because
I had the objective of building this and
by building that launching it making a
little bit of money is what sort of
opened my eyes to the fact that you
could build these applications make
money and over the next two three years
I just built hundreds and hundreds of
apps and basically scale that business
out so these are just apps that you
would find like on the App Store but
then you charge some sort of like
subscription service or internet reviews
ad Revenue was our primary revenue
Channel because then we moved to
personality quizzes so you would you
would get a notification wait is this
the Facebook personality quiz yeah
exactly we were at the OG's like we I
remember yeah but you were doing this
back when Facebook was that it's like
hey Dave correct I remember like
everyone was on Facebook like 2006 to
2010. it was attacked by like science or
was it kind of just like no so so
there's this thing called uh which Harry
Potter are you there's this thing called
the Barnum effect which says that like
it's the attribute of us to read a
description and to like kind of see how
it belong how like you identify with it
right and a lot of these quizzes sort of
work the same way where you could come
up with the description and a lot of
people think that about themselves like
you could like no matter what you answer
in a quiz I could tell you
you're mysterious people think they know
you or do they really know you yeah
the exact same way about horoscopes
arbitrary that anybody
can be like you know what I'm a Libra
you know me I'm a Libra what it was but
I read uh someone who's really into
horoscopes I read something completely
different for like a different sign and
they're like yeah that exactly like
that's not even yours though yeah the
the other thing we found is a lot of
people used these quizzes not to find
out anything about themselves but to
find the right snippet to share so what
we would see for instance is let's say
there's a quiz which Friends character
are you they would take the quiz
repeatedly till they got the answer they
wanted and then shared it yep so because
remember right there's a social aspect
of this as well it's not just wanting to
know it it's wanting to tell everyone
who you are so someone would take the
quiz four times they're finally Joey and
then they share that one wow so and then
it makes everyone else want to see which
one yeah so it was a short that is so
funny it was a shortcut to learning a
lot about human psychology right like as
we're building these apps and seeing
everything
um yeah it was really cool and yeah by
the end of that by the time I was you
know 2021
um had me drill money through those apps
and it's you know opened my eyes to the
power of building something how much
were those making so a lot of them
peaked it like like when they got really
really big it only lasted for a few days
but it we literally hit a daily maximum
of 50 000 a day
um yeah and over the course of the apps
and like I think it made over a million
dollars you know over the few years no
some of them obviously were not
successful what percentage did not hit
and which were those apps like why did
they fail ironically anything that was
useful and had utility
was a struggle it was a struggle like I
mean you build a calendar app you build
stuff that was actually like helpful to
people it didn't really work the things
that worked were basically things that
appealed to vanity right so friend
quizzes worked really well uh which was
you answer a question about your friend
so you get a notification
maybe you get a notification it's like
maybe it's a it's a girl be like this
girl will answer the question do you
think Graham is cute click here to find
out what she said and now it'll take you
inside the quiz but to unlock her answer
you have to answer about 20 other of
your friends or you know yeah and you're
sending ads to him the entire way well
no so there's ads at the bottom but you
can also alternatively pay a dollar or
do like a dollar worth of activities to
unlock the answer without answering the
question so it was this idea of a
virtual currency where
um you know you could sign up for a
Netflix trial or do these all these
other things to unlock the answer
oh it was a snapshot again it's like
human psychology and my partner at the
time built a very sophisticated system
where we would input thousands of
questions it would rank each question's
viral coefficient because some questions
were better than others then
automatically update the highest
performing questions in real time so it
works really well it was a pretty
sophisticated system for the time but
yeah it was it was a lot of fun I
remember something on MySpace where they
came out with what was an anonymous
question it could have been Facebook but
it's when you could you ask your
audience a question they could respond
back but it's Anonymous you could be
like do you think I'm cute and everyone
respond I've seen that like I have no
idea you stayed far from that because
when we tried that there was like
bullying and stuff so that was the thing
you have to be careful of uh but yeah a
couple of things we did that was really
good is we once had this uh it would
open the app it would predict your best
friends and we people would be blown
away by how accurate our predictions
were and all we would do is look at
their photos and see who are they tagged
in the most number of photos with it
works so well so it's like open this app
we'll guess who your best friends are
and then people will be like wow how did
you figure this out would you manually
guess it or did you no no it's
programmatics programmatically what it
would do is but look at all your
Facebook photos it would see who you
share the most photos with because all
photos were tagged oh okay so we would
rank them by who you're in the most
photos with so it was very very accurate
now that relies on Facebook giving you
all that data how easy was it for
Facebook it was if you remember yeah
remember the whole Cambridge analytics
Saga yeah the reason that existed is
Facebook gave you everything back in the
day you could get all open People added
an application you could see everything
their friends their friends friends like
their photos with their in photos with
interest everything so at that time that
was all available yeah I had a crazy
this is when it really hit me
um I think this was early days of
Facebook I had purchased with a debit
card uh like a deal like an Old Spice
deodorant or something like that and
then as soon as I went on Facebook right
afterwards I'd start getting ads of the
Facebook deodorant and I believe it was
because I linked my phone number with my
Facebook that was also linked to the
debit card or something like that and
that was shared and they made that
connection that Graham just purchased
deodorant let me show them this on
Facebook and hopefully he buys it again
it's wild how do you prevent that is
that when I asked like do you want to
accept cookies on this page I feel like
it's the I feel like no I feel like in
the beginning this is like you sign up
for Facebook now Facebook now has
changed their terms like now Facebook
does not give any information to third
parties after the whole Cambridge
analytica thing I think they realized
that parties that were interested could
like abuse that data like for us we
didn't care like we use it for these
quizzes I never saved that data the
server space to save it is too expensive
like why would I care about it but now
they don't give you any of that
interesting and you have apple too and
it's really cracked down on that for for
sharing how do you how did you justify
in college when you're at Berkeley
staying in college when you're making so
much money like you could have just like
got that job being an Indian man it's
being Indian like every time I talk to
my parents about dropping out they're
like no just just do it but I I was able
to find a good balance I didn't I didn't
spend that I didn't go to class really I
would study right before midterms and
finals I did okay
um and I I just was like let me take the
path of least resistance which was
taking the easiest classes to get my
degree but yeah multiple points I'm like
I don't understand the point of this and
I came close to dropping out but I I you
know stuck it through what do you think
about like because I feel like if you
take the path of least resistance and
you still do well meanwhile not working
very hard like that's something that
schools should appreciate and like
celebrate right because that's but
that's what I'm going that's what I
appreciate about the American system
because I went to high school in an
Indian high school and there was no
substitute for just like doing a lot of
work but the American college system
there's a lot of potential for being
smart about it right you have to hit a
certain number of credits but you can go
to a professor get credits for doing all
these random activities you can choose
classes in a certain way that it give
you there was a system and like any
system any good system I wanted to beat
it and you know I found a way to like
find easy classes find easy professors
like find certain classes I could take
over the summer where it was much easier
so it doesn't make sense yeah there's a
system to consistent to defeat and you
know that's what I did is rape my
professor still a thing yeah it is yeah
I had that at that yeah yeah I was
wondering if you just look up music I
wonder so I still remember and I wonder
if like this is still appropriate but at
the time raped by Professor also had
attacked with professors that were hot
and I feel like today I don't had it
used to yeah it was physically
attractive spicy like yeah
I bet that's probably gone but yeah back
in the day they had all that oh my gosh
yeah how much would it cost you to
develop some of these apps that you were
making back then I mean most of it was
pretty trivial I built so
firstly I built the app that were very
simple to do then I would get my
roommates involved and they would all
create content and we'd you know create
would split the revenue and stuff but
then in addition to running these apps I
would take the source code and sell the
source code as well so you're selling
pics and Shop I was selling everything
yeah so would sell the source code for
you know 500 a thousand dollars
um so anyone could take that and build
an app with it did you not worry that
people would just copy your designs and
run you out of business yeah but I
figured like it's so simple that if I
wasn't selling it someone else would so
I may as well alter it happen to that
did your brother get one percent equity
now my brother had no idea
for one of my roommates had Equity as I
built these different businesses with
them and then what happened to that did
it just fizzle out did you sell it So
eventually these businesses they would
like you know application would grow and
they would eventually sort of Peter out
so there's no Enterprise Value being
built so I did sell a few of them but if
I sold them it would be sold for like
trailing 30 days Revenue 60 days Revenue
there's not a lot of Yale
um and the other ones just died in
natural death eventually it would get to
a couple million people and then it
would have its moment in the Sun and be
be done got it yep what did you do after
college so I ran this for a little bit
after college but I think around 21 I
graduated college at 28 around 21 this
was fully done and I spent two years
figuring out what I wanted to do so I
wanted to start a business tried lots of
ideas but it was two maybe three years
of just nothing working so probably
tried eight to ten different startup
ideas at the time uh nothing quite
worked somewhere in the middle of that I
moved to New York City and then when I
was 23 24 started doing a little bit of
teaching uh both in person and general
assembly and then online on udemy and
that slowly evolved into starting
teachable but between the Facebook apps
and starting teachable it was just a lot
of trying things that didn't work were
you just living off of the over a
million dollars you had earned from all
the apps and everything as a comfortable
yeah it was comfortable I mean
comfortable in the sense of my lifestyle
at no point especially then was
extravagant like I did not like despite
making that kind of money at 21 I did
not like Buy anything dumb and you know
but it was very comfortable so what was
your idea process like for for thinking
of different concepts would you just
think for a while did you have a notepad
writing down ideas I would just try and
find something and act upon it instantly
because I find like inspiration is very
fleeting so less thinking more doing uh
but yeah we're all over the place I had
a a couple of the ideas were good we
just executed them poorly like an app
where you could like order your like
order toothpaste and stuff that we never
quite built the Fulfillment so we just
ordered of Amazon and people then just
realized they could order to Amazon
directly but you know there's something
over there we built a domain name
registrar to buy your name.com or we had
a lot of different ideas but nothing
nothing quite work
um until starting teachable I want to
tell you my two ideas and you you give
me your honest thoughts you rank them
okay two ideas here the first one I'll
get to that one Jack the first one I
wanted to create an app that was called
parked where people could rent out their
driveways yep because I remember in
Venice Beach Santa Monica you could not
find a parking spot but there were so
many empty driveways what if they just
have an app where you check in in their
driveway you could park there and it
charges you per minute so unlike a
parking meter where you just like you
have to guess it's just charge you for a
minute and then uh but anyway there's a
there's a company in San Francisco that
tried that two of them and they both
failed and I thought well if they're
doing it and both of them fail yeah
I'm gonna fail on that too what do you
think of that idea I think it depends on
like what you what your goal is right
like the reason a lot of startups fail
is because for a startup to be viable if
you raise Venture Capital you're really
looking for an exit that could be
billion dollars billion dollars plus and
a lot of these turn out to be really
nice small businesses good cash flow a
few million dollars a year but because
you go the Venture route it's not doable
so my inclination with something like
that is it could totally be a really
nice business it's probably not Venture
scaled so I think someone could make a
nice living off it but it's not the idea
I would raise money for I think the
company in San Francisco probably fell
into the Trap of like raising Venture
dollars for it and realizing it's a cool
opportunity just not big enough for a
venture size outcome got it I think the
other issue with that was that a lot of
the houses that were in Prime parking
locations were worth millions of dollars
the liability of having someone park
there to earn like you know 10 cents and
yes a minute or something like that
probably wasn't worth it the other idea
that I came up with that I thought was
pretty good it was called Truth
intel.com where basically it was a Yelp
for people where you could go and make a
profile for someone else upload their
photo and write a review on them like
Yelp and uh it was crazy but we started
this we had a buddy who did all the
coding back and we created the website
and we created a fake Facebook account
and we just added thousands of people on
this Facebook yeah and then we started
promoting truth and tell this is back in
like 2010 am I doing this for like
people I'm dating Friends Business
Associates across the world we just
thought it would be an interesting
concept because there's no uh directory
or like review of a person yep it was
like a Black Mirror episode kind of like
something like that but like my thinking
is like okay let's say let's say for
dating you show up to somebody they're
they're creepy they show up late they're
disrespectful
it would be helpful because there was an
app in San Francisco for girls to read I
remember that yeah the goals to rate you
they got so much where like if you're a
man you couldn't even sign up for it but
it was like girls telling other girls
about guys they're dating it was like
the centralized directory the problem
with all these ideas is like one it's
Rife for bullying yes it's right for
like really bad behavior and two like
incentives are kind of skewed right like
if you could theoretically like if I you
pissed me off I could go there and like
kind of hurt your reputation irrevocably
for just my own angst or whatever yeah
that's why we never went with it yeah uh
we the more we looked into it the more
we realized that people only write
reviews if they're upset if it's ever
positive they're less likely to write
this like every one positive review you
probably have 10 great experiences with
their own talk yeah versus you have one
bad experience you have one bad view
like the ratios are off there so we
never pursued it yep yep I thought that
would be interesting if there's a way to
do it legitimately I always had an idea
it was uh you know the unclaimed funds
the directory or whatever I wanted to go
on there and then figure out a way where
I could scrub through all the data and
then figure these people's addresses out
send them a letter something like hey
computer companies do that there are
companies that do that do they make just
a role in it yeah I was thinking like
find a way but like also it's based off
of good faith because it's their money
already so how would I be entitled to
any of that something like you know you
could just make a charitable donation
because I made you aware of this which
is very easy you know just to get all
that data contract I get it do they
really yeah some guy reached out to me
he was an old like an older guy and uh
sounded like he was in the 70s or 80s
and told me the same thing is like you
have a few thousand dollars that's
unclaimed that belongs to you and it's
not on the website if you search for it
or like he told me like this obscure
thing but he said he wanted me to sign
something with my Social Security giving
him power of attorney to clean it on my
behalf and I talked to him it's kind of
sketchy though right like you don't know
what he's going to do right exactly so I
said no but I said how about this if you
trust me on this one I will pay you but
I gotta claim myself and he went on a
limb he gave me the information where to
find it how to claim it and I paid him
what what was it so basically the
uncommissioned that was sent to an old
address or something like that uh and
was never claimed the unclaimed fund is
really cool if you guys are listening
you can see if you have just any money
that was sent to you maybe you moved
houses so it got sent back to the post
office or whatever it all goes to this
one main database where you can log once
the identifier you're social or how do
they know it's like your name your
address and that's all public
information too so you can look up other
people's names see what unclaimed funds
they have where it got sent and
everything very easy to search up I
thought the hard part about that was
that each state has their own process
for unclaimed funds no they don't uh no
I think they do yeah yeah and so I
thought that's what makes it more
difficult because
um because each state is separate and
then you've lived in multiple states
what states do you check and I think
that that's where a lot of those
companies profit because let's say you
used to live in Texas when you were 18
and 19 but then you moved to California
a lot of the companies I think are just
scrubbing every single state and you
would never think that check Texas
because they're like I lived there two
years yeah yeah it's a good business
it's hard to scale though and you got
and the person has to either have power
of attorney or claim it themselves it's
difficult to claim I hated it like you
have to mail something in and then you
have to wait like weeks I think it was
like nine to 12 weeks to get your money
back so and usually unless it's like
more than a hundred dollars it's not
even worth it there's plenty they're
like four or five dollars on there like
you're gonna pay more and post it right
I I tried for one of my friends dads I
was just looking up everybody in my
contacts it was like 12 Grand like
unclaimed funds I'm like twelve thousand
dollars I texted my friend and he was I
was like dude does your dad look man
I'll do this for free you know obviously
like hoping to maybe get a little bit of
money on the back end maybe a few
hundred bucks or something and then he
he looked it up and it was the exact
same name as his dad like oh and what's
right near his address different person
wow right near where he lived same name
as his dad the other guy could probably
claim it and they wouldn't know all
right it was twelve thousand dollars
there you go very well could yeah well
actually the socials wouldn't match up
oh true so no you couldn't do that but
anyways yeah enough on our past business
ideas uh let's talk about teachable yeah
because that was like the not the
end-all be-all but kind of like the
thing that really yeah got you going yep
absolutely uh yeah ended up I had a
couple of courses I on udemy was you
know making a few thousand dollars a
month teaching but soon realized that
when you're on someone else's platform
you can't really scale it because they
control pricing I would work hard to
bring students to my udemy course but
then they cross sold my competitors
courses all of that made me realize it's
very very hard to scale a business so I
ended up building again a very simple
app for myself and my my buddy Conrad to
put our own courses on our own website
uh it was a little side project at the
time and yeah it worked for us and then
we got customer number two three four
and six months in made me realize we may
have a business
um and then went to Silicon Valley ended
up raising money for it and Off to the
Races we went what was that process like
in the beginning when did you what was
the moment you realize this could be a
business like how much were you making
at that time so I think it was when we
got our second and third customer at
which point the total course sailed on
the platform were about five ten
thousand dollars we kept fifteen percent
so 1500 a month which is but more than
that there's the path to scale it that
was when I started thinking there may be
a business by the time we actually
raised money we were I think making
about you know four or five thousand
dollars a month a little bit more
um and we're like okay I think it's time
time to go to Silicon Valley and raise
around and all that how do you do that
how do you just decide to go to Silicon
Valley and just so this is where the
Facebook app stuff was helpful because I
had already gone to school at Berkeley
so I'd known a lot of met a lot of
investors during my time there and I had
a roster of people I could go back to
being like hey you know I met you when I
was 19 20 years old
um are you interested in investing even
then it was two months of rejections two
months of everyone being really nice
saying we love it and not following up
until we got our first investor this guy
named Matt brezina who did not realize
he was their first investor actually he
said yeah I'd love to invest um let me
know Bank details and I immediately ran
Incorporated the company that day went
to the Bank of America near my house and
replied back and like yeah here's our
wire info no big deal
um but yeah it was it was quite a
process to get our first first what what
did that deal look like in terms of like
how much was invested and how much did
you need or was it I'm wondering why you
even decided to raise when it's I feel
like a pretty low overhead Engineers are
expensive you know like if I were to
like summarize it in like one sentence
Engineers are expensive I had written
the code for the first version of the
app I'm a bad engineer like you know
like what I built was great for
validating a side project you can't
build a company with what I built so we
had to go out and hire people and you
know at the time Engineers were you know
maybe a hundred thousand dollars Euro be
the starting salary it's gone up a lot
since then but even that you can't
bootstrap that
um so I ended up I didn't know how much
to raise I picked numbers I was like oh
that's today's one million dollars at an
8 million valuation and we kept shopping
it around until someone said yes why is
it an 8 million valuation and not a six
or ten I can't tell you they're all
equally arbitrary uh but that's where we
went yeah I feel like a lot of those
startups because uh we have our mutual
friend uh sebi and a lot of them I hear
how do you come to that and it just
seems like they all pick like you know
25 million or 20 million 50 million like
they just pick these numbers yep uh and
raised from that yeah but it's all
equally arbitrary right like I had an
investor say hey this sounds like a six
million dollar deal not an eight million
dollar deal I'm like your number is as
arbitrary as mine like neither of us can
actually justify this uh but for me I
kept saying eight until someone said yes
and then we went with it how much did
you need and what was the runway how
much did that give you so we we
originally aimed for one and we then
ended up getting a little bit more a
little bit closer to two but the goal
typically is you want to underestimate
or say a smaller number so that you can
fill it up and go above because if you
have too high a number and you don't hit
it it's a worse signal but again our
round was it took a very long time to
get the first check but after that
everything else happened in two weeks is
that because you could say this other
person invested yes investors are like
very scared of moving by themselves and
when you have momentum AKA other
investors are on board and for us one of
the turning points was when Naval the
founder of angelist came on board and
messaged his Syndicate on Angel list yep
then the rest around happened in the
weekend I think it was like the Fourth
of July weekend and like just over that
weekend we got everything oh my God
what's the average amount that someone
would invest in a startup uh so for us
we had I would say if I were to guess
our average we had a few 25k checks a
few 50k checks and a few hundred K
checks
um that was sort of the typical sort of
range do you think that's typical of
just industry standard that most people
or individuals yes for funds it's it's
larger for individuals I think that
makes yeah it was sebby that told me
that
um I think it was one and only one in 25
on average is gonna hit is that true so
like you have to on average invest 25
times about one to make up for all the
losses yes I mean I think it depends
like let's say out of 25 companies what
I think it might actually look like is
10 companies return zero
um you know another 10 companies return
roughly your money back a little bit
here or there maybe three return to X
but one of those is what will return 10
or 20x or 50x and that's where you make
your money when you look at where you
make your profits from as an investor
it's typically one company or two
companies and you could have a hundred
companies that have you know returned
very little yeah so when you got that
initial funding did that last you for
like a year or two or like how did you
structure that it lost it yeah so I mean
that allowed us to hire four people and
from that with that you know we had a
couple of years of Runway but then at
every point we ended up raising more
money inbound that we never ever got
close to spending all of it in fact over
the lifetime of teachable we raised 12
million dollars and we had nine in the
the bank when we saw oh my God so once
the business started working we ran it
pretty close to profitability not fully
profitable this might sound silly why
raise money when you don't have to
because I feel like it's it's much more
powerful to retain more ownership than
raise way more than you need I think
there's a deal structure that works for
everything the last round before we sold
we raised four million dollars at 130
million pre-money valuation so it means
we sold 30 of our company for four
million dollars so I would say you're
selling so little yes so even then
though a lot of investors didn't want to
invest in us because we didn't want to
sell 20 so I'm with you right if you
don't have to sell you can do these
weird rounds where you sell three
percent four percent where you don't
feel much and four million made me feel
a lot better about my company's you know
cash position so I think there's the
other the other thing is I also think
it's helpful to have the right investors
on board so jumping forward a little
with my new company raising a lot of
money just from dope people in fact no
one can invest more than ten thousand uh
but we're raising one to ten thousand
dollars from you know a couple hundred
dope people because it's nice to have
Smart connected Network people invested
in our success yeah so how much of that
is money versus how much is just getting
someone on board that you could pop on a
call with them and ask them questions
much more that and also like this Army
of supporters whenever to help us tell
our story got it yeah so grown teachable
what was that like once you hired these
people how did you find more creators to
go on the platform yeah so I mean again
like it was it took quite a while to hit
any kind of scale it took us almost it
took us a long time to get to about a
million dollars in annualized Revenue
but from that point actually took us
quite a while to get to 5K in monthly
Revenue but from that point we were able
to grow much faster after really
figuring how to Market which for us was
leveraging other creators audiences we
realized something pretty special
um and you're a teachable Creator is a
lot of our top creators people who
followed them and looked up to them were
also potential teachable creators so we
ran a lot of webinars a lot of events
our affiliate program is very big as
soon as you figured out that go to
market motion we were able to scale much
much faster but even it wasn't easy I
mean it took many years and you know
continually figuring out lots of
different things and yeah eventually we
got there now I remember something about
you having very few creators on the
platform but your Revenue was so
substantial compared to how many people
were on there right what what did that
look like yeah so in general we made
money from our creators not the students
so we would charge our creators on
average about 70 dollars a month in
software and we made a little bit on
payments on average we make about a
thousand dollars a Creator a year and
from that point on it was just what can
we do to acquire the most number of
creators and some of the creators made a
lot of money like we had a Creator who
made you know 20 million dollars and on
an average year we'd have you know like
tens of creators and make over a million
dollars a year so real real money
um and yeah and they would still only
pay us you know about a thousand dollars
a year so it was pretty good value for
them since we didn't charge a percentage
of sales how long did it take for you to
unteachable for it to be profitable we
were never profitable we were always
close to profitability we were always
three months if I didn't hire anyone for
three months we'd be profitable it's
roughly higher in the car so you're just
focused on just growing as fast as
possible well you know yeah like so at
any I would say our average burn may
have been like you know 30 to 50K so
that's like three people or whatever so
if we were continually growing so if I
don't if I stop hiring people for a
quarter we'd be profitable in three
months that's sort of how we ran and was
the goal always to sell eventually the
goal was never to sell the goal was the
goal was yeah just keep building the
company but we ended up getting an offer
at the right time from the right people
which was this company called hot Mart
in Brazil and what I like the most about
them is they're a founder-led Founder
driven company
um like met the founders in New York and
yeah just really liked their energy
realized we saw the world the exact same
way and it had also been at the time
almost six years of building the company
the timing just seemed right and yeah it
was just a match sort of made in heaven
but at no point did I you know go out to
try and sell the company and we'd never
we never looked for a deal the deal
found us yeah what were your biggest
challenges in scaling people uh it's
just like I love creating things but I
realized I didn't like operating things
as much like I you know creating
something is so exciting it's a
completely different skill it's a high
it's a rush to build something where
nothing exists but to operate something
to hire managers who manage other people
you're so far away from creating I
personally find that very challenging I
find it hard to get excited about that I
burnt out numerous multiple times found
it hard to recruit sort of Executives
because executives are so different from
Founders right a great executive is
nothing like a great founder
um so that was stuff I struggled with
and I think that also realistically
probably contributed to making me more
likely to sell is the fact that I think
I was starting to feel a bit burnt out
of managing managers of operating
running a company of you know a couple
hundred people and you're always dealing
with problems versus the excitement of
creating something what were some of the
problems you had to deal with it was
just people man it was always at every
given stage it's like the I'll give you
an example right so because of the
structure we were at if you wanted to do
if you wanted to build something new
when you're a five-person company you
just go ahead and do it now we would
have to talk about it in our annual
planning meeting which would then have a
budgeting process associated with it
we'd then work it into our quarterly
roadmap and we'd then start have you
know so from the time you want to do
something cool till it happens is like
12 months or something and that just
takes a lot of the fun out of it and
yeah and I constantly had this feeling
that I am also probably not the best CEO
for the company it was also this nagging
sense of like not only am I not enjoying
this there's someone out there who's an
amazing CEO and they should be the one
running this and is that I don't know if
this is the right word but like
bureaucracy within business like that
adds all those logistical issues just
something that needs to start happening
once you go to that level or is it like
a government type thing like it's policy
honestly I also don't know is this
inevitable or not some degree if it is
inevitable but I'm not sure again all
right my first time running a company if
I'm sure I could have done it and set it
up in a better way as well some level of
process is inevitable but I think we may
have had too much and it may have been
my causing for all you know right so
that's sort of the the stuff that I
thought a lot about and to be quite
candid I also think I had a lot of ego
attached to being CEO then that I didn't
just let go like like knowing what I
know now if I were to be in a similar
situation I would probably walk away and
hire someone who's a hired CEO and have
no ego about it but the first time
you're like oh you know I want to be
it's my company I want to be the boss I
want to be the CEO
um so I think there's definitely an ego
play as well what was your day-to-day
schedule like back then meetings just
meeting the meetings and meetings yep
um so I would guess you you know the
core like year four year five I'm
spending 60 to 70 of my calendar in
meetings which was again Soul crushing
and yeah all of these things sort of
made it when you know when we got closer
to the acquisition it seemed more
appealing to be able to like
have more creative freedom and stuff
like that how do you learn how to do all
of this is it just figure it out figure
it out yeah exactly I think it helps to
talk to a lot of people so that's why I
raised money from other Founders and
it's always very helpful to talk to
Founders who've gone through the same
process and you know learned from them
and then there's also just a case of
like iterating you try something it
works it you know it and then you get
better
funnily enough doing this again what I
will now do is trust my instincts more
the first time around you feel like you
don't know what you're doing so you
almost listen too much to other people
while now I just feel more comfortable
that no one really knows anything and
you may as well be authentic to what
gives you the most energy and trusting
your own instincts more and can you say
how much you've sold it for yeah I mean
again I I'm not allowed to officially
confirm or deny a number based on our
deal but you know there's an article
that says it was somewhere in the range
of 250 million dollars
that's directionally accurate got it and
what was that like for was that a number
that we we can't confirm or deny but was
that an amount where you're just like
holy crap like is this real or at that
point I didn't have a number I mean I
just wanted to get a fair price for the
company and by fair price I didn't want
the best price I wanted like the 89 80th
90th percentile price and based on what
the business was at the time which was
doing I don't know I think was 20
million dollars a year when we were
negotiating the deal and 25 million
dollars a year when we sold it it was a
good price I don't think it was an
outrageous price I think it was a pretty
good price
um and that that's just what the
business was worth I don't think it
wasn't a number I had to hit like if if
we had been a bigger business I would
have wanted more or small business
wanted less and you can't say exactly
how much your stake or equity in that
company was at the time no but I mean a
good amount I mean it's you know it
ended up uh and the deal was half cash
half stock because I'm also optimistic
about you know what podmark the parent
company is doing and and you know on
part was treated very very well there
and continue to be involved there at the
board and all of that yeah so what did
you do after signing the contract having
it done
took six months in between because
structuring a deal as you learn there's
so much nitty-gritty and stuff and why
the day we ended up signing the deal
right this is the day like the deal was
done
um was the day that the stock market had
the biggest crash in history because
this was when covid was becoming a thing
oh man and the day we announced the deal
was two days after New York shut down so
it was very interesting I'm like I just
sold a company for a lot of money yet I
cannot leave my apartment since we're in
lockdown for the next two months but but
yeah overall I mean I think it was a
sense of like gratitude
and also just like also just recognizing
our privilege at the time because at the
time New York was going through a really
bad wave it was so much uncertainty and
yeah it was an interesting time little
did you know though that like that
lockdown I'm sure for teachable oh yeah
or business doubled our business doubled
right after we sold the company
um do you ever look back and think oh
man had I just waited no because he
still sold right half of what you sold
out but I also don't for a very specific
reason and that is like
I feel so fortunate for everything life
has given me I don't want to be a rich
who's like oh man I wish I could
have had more like in general like you
know there's two paths it can either be
so grateful I'm like like life has been
so so so so so so good to me that
yes could have sold it a different time
for more money yeah but like if you're
going to talk about all the things that
could have gone even better like just be
grateful right like you can't even enjoy
your wealth yeah yeah like so much so
much has gone so right for me to have
what I have who cares about you anything
else is like yeah I love that mentality
I asked Tom Billy this from Quest but
when you sold the company let's just say
I'm just gonna say a random number could
be completely wrong right but if you got
50 million in cash in like another 50
million or whatever in stocks did that
money just hit a bank account it was
just no I mean so whatever yeah did the
whole thing hits and you pay taxes on
that later like you say with the most
that you had in that checking account
before
yeah all before yeah
I don't know like I'm reading his face
and as it starts to Grimace and I'm like
okay but before but before uh I mean I
can tell it my salary at the time was
150 Grand a year
um like tens is like probably like 20K
or something like that 20K yeah but yeah
so yeah I've published talked about how
much I paid myself I mean I was paying
myself I think I started paying myself
70 grand then 105 then 120 then 150 and
it was at 150 we're like I'm not not
making any more dollars as for my salary
you went from twenty thousand dollars in
a checking account yeah or savings
account or whatever to well into the
eight figures yep Jack's next question
is like if you could express that change
in a percentage
or a factor or it doesn't matter
yeah God how did that how did that
change your life afterwards uh changed
okay so I mean we're in the house right
I was able to like move out of my 400
square foot apartment and buy a house
um the things that added meaningful
value is family I was able to like oh
actually an interesting point so my
happiness did not change at all when the
money came in the bank it did not change
at all
um post selling my company but nine
months after that when I stopped being
CEO I became substantially happier so
first sort of lesson was like the money
was indirectly made me happy by giving
me freedom but the freedom was what
actually made me happy
um another way that it like greatly
improved my life is I was able to like
just one see my family a lot more to
take the family room like more vacations
and like yeah just hang out with my like
parents much more and being able to do
that stuff for them I think was was
really really great but for my own life
I think it was
I think I heard someone Express this
really well where they're like when they
had money the best part is it solved the
money problem it's not like buying fancy
things but it's at no point are you
stressed about money you go to a
restaurant you're not stressed about
like wherever you go like money is just
something you don't think about and to
me that's been the most valuable thing
is I don't think or stress about money
and that's something that again I kind
of remind myself of because I know so
many rich people who have more money
than I am but they're still stressed
about it they either want more or like
upset about how much they pay in taxes
or something and it's like for me the
money problem was solved and that's
super valuable I don't think about it
it's it's great and then after selling
how did you get back on the horse to
build another business yeah so ended up
selling the company started started a
fund invested and while I was investing
I was traveling a ton I told myself I
never wanted to start a company again
because in my mind I just remembered how
hard it was but you know a couple years
pass
um after a while I realized I missed the
sort of meaning I got from building a
company and also it's it's a little bit
where I do think I'm actually good at
creating a business and like you know
it's like I'm like an athlete who misses
playing their sport I'm like you know
that's my that's my thing I I miss it I
want to compete I want to you know I
wanna I wanna put my hat in the ring one
more time and build something super
valuable I think this time it will be
the last time I do this uh because I
want to build something really really
valuable but I had one one big swing in
me could you tell us more about that
yeah absolutely so the new company it's
based on my learnings while I was
selling my business right before selling
my business I hired lawyers and
accountants and all these expensive
Finance people to help me figure out how
the tax code Works how to structure
stuff and it made me realize there's a
lot of things people don't know about
like in terms of how to actually keep
the money you make there's this whole
black magic that is thus far only been
for rich people right whether it's like
setting up trust or like how to best
leverage retirement accounts and all the
these things and I'm like
people need to know about this everyone
needs to know about this so the goal
with this business is to help business
owners keep more of the money they make
and we'll do that by teaching them how
to but also Building Products so we
built a product that's a retirement
account for anyone who works for
themselves and they'll keep building
products like this but really things
that help people understand this crazy
tax code we have and keep more of the
money they make all right um teach me
let me be the case what could you where
would you start just pretend like I am
your student right now okay so the first
thing I would talk about is like
wherever possible I think being a
business owner is amongst the most tax
advantage thing you can do there are so
many benefits right from the fact of
like capital gains right like you pay a
lower tax rate by owning assets versus
cash the worst type of income to have is
a salary but within that there's so many
sort of different optimizations based on
where people are and what they want to
what they want to do so again what
started very basic but like if it's
someone who's making you know 150 000 a
year sell playing courses what I would
tell them is one you probably the
problem you're set up as an LLC they
probably want to move to an S corp
because they'll save on self-employment
taxes they probably want to make sure
they're claiming their deductions
correctly of all of their expenses right
like right from home office internet all
of that stuff
um want to make go through their
businesses there anything they can
depreciate if there any real estate tied
to their business there's appreciation
stuff there's business tax credits and
that's for that type of person if you're
a startup founder there's something
called qsbs which is where you pay no
taxes and up to 10 million dollars when
you sell your company but you can set up
a trust and multiply that to 20 or 30
million no matter what the scenarios
there's a lot of crazy stuff and our
goal is to teach people how to do that
so this is stuff that a good accountant
should know yes a good accountant should
should know not all of them do yeah
um and then some things are the
technology so a retirement account for
one person like I tried to set one up
myself it was impossible which is why we
built a technology ourselves where
someone is self-employed we set up a
401k for themselves but the cool thing
with the solo 401K is you can invest it
in any asset you want you can invest it
in startups crypto real estate and you
can get a 67 000 a year tax deduction uh
if you want you can also do Roth
contributions which mean it you never
pay a dollar of tax on it post
retirement and there's no income limits
unlike a Roth IRA which is limited to
people who make less than 150 000 a year
a Roth solo 401K there's no income limit
so you can make a million dollars a year
and still put in Sixty seven thousand
dollars into a Roth 401k using something
called a mega backdoor conversion which
again is like Niche tax strategy so I
did one of those uh last year and it was
one of the most complicated
like honestly for me just to set up all
of the different accounts and get them
to communicate with each other and stuff
it probably took close to two weeks I
got started it was like December 7th and
I was like okay like I'm good I have
like three weeks nearly four weeks to
get all this situated and everything
start creating account here create an
account here I have to link these
accounts I have to wait for this like
thing to get settled and then I have to
like withdraw the money here it was
incredible it was it took so long and I
almost didn't get it in time I think I
got it on like the last day possible and
I had so much money in wire fees for and
like crazy it's crazy it's terrible it
was so stressful and I hated it wait a
minute you made a a Roth no no sorry a
yeah the Rother a back door yeah yeah
and uh what was the limit on on the 60
on the 401K at 67. no no no what was the
limit on the regular Roth IRA uh if you
make over 150 000 a year Jack are you
trying to say that
that was I mean yeah I did um because I
contributed to it but yeah that was it
was extremely uh yeah yeah also a rock
Ira only lets you contribute 6 500 a
year but using a mega backdoor Rod you
can get 67 000 in so more than 10 times
into a retirement account and these
compound packs free right so again like
there's stories I don't know if you read
about Peter Thiel during his Roth IRA to
four billion in value
right now
it was two steps one he bought his
Paypal Founders and then that grew to
about 20 30 million then he made all his
Investments including 500k and Facebook
from the Roth but again like these are
things and by the way I do think what he
did was probably slightly illegal and we
tell people like you know this is what
he did I wouldn't do it for these
reasons but there's such a dark art here
that our goal is let's talk about it
let's build tools for it let's build a
technology apology for it and teach
people you know how to keep more of the
money they make because when you run
your business at least for me you spend
so long thinking about your business no
one's thinking about your personal
finances and that's where we want to
want to come in I love that but how
would that be different from a competent
accountant one we're building technology
right we're building like in a
complicated like all the accountants
we're partnering with they're using our
technology to actually set up the solo
401k and as we build more products we're
going to use our software to do that and
two the education is helpful for all the
people who can't afford an accountant so
the education it's like it's education
is two three hundred dollars a year and
you get all this information it's a
community it's courses I mean it's
education business so so yeah
um the technology is really the
differentiator where again like
accountants will use us but like we'll
be a One-Stop solution for you to
deposit money do a conversion invest in
startups invest in stocks ETFs
everything it's a full Investing
platform so if someone were to sell
their business for let's say some
hypothetical number 250 million dollars
would they need all of the accountants
and attorneys what would they just use
here so I would at that scale I like
again we still recommend accountants for
anyone who makes a bunch of money but as
this person is building their business
they can learn a lot of things about how
to set things up while kind of going
through our content but when it's time
for the exit I would still always
recommend you know an accountant and so
forth and does it provide consulting or
is it mostly just like education so
right now it's education and Technology
products I think there's a world where
we will find a way to work with advisors
as well because I think you can I still
am I still think you the human touch is
very very important when you're dealing
with people's money might be a little
bit of uh Ramsay Solutions where he has
people that you go through that are
pre-approved that know his system and uh
he's kind of the broker between the two
yep yeah the the big difference is long
term we also want to build the best sort
of investing platform out there so the
fact that right now we just you know we
became a registered investment advisor
we're soon rolling out the ability with
one click to buy stocks and ETFs from
the app so it's a full investment
platform as well
is it is it operational now
the company's been around for four
months we've rushed out our 401K product
because we needed to hit a December 31st
deadline so we have you know hundreds of
people that set up their 401K product
with us already next month we're
launching investing uh yeah We're Off to
the Races the education product launches
in two days so lots of the one downside
I will say with a lot of the 401ks is
that the investment options are terrible
that's why 401K is amazing because all
the power for 401k but you decide how to
invest it you guys have a referral or
affiliate program well we'll give you a
link oh yeah oh well if you guys want to
check it out all right well now it's
linked down below write down in the
description maybe a pinned comment yeah
yeah that's interesting I I can't
remember who I went through or go
through for a 401k but I had to set one
up as an employee with
I think it was a ADP or something like
that yeah they're they're Terr and
that's the other thing we're thinking
about there's a good chance we've gotten
a lot of demand from startups and small
businesses that say Hey this is dope for
my one person business but I would love
to use it I started over my 20 or 30
companies there's a good chance we'll
end up servicing that demographic as
well I think you would need to because
that's the big Market there's a lot of
Market there and and like a lot of the
competitors charge assets under
management fees and I think I think AUM
fees are a rip-off typically like I
think it's great for the provider like
we would make so much money if we
charged a fee of assets under management
but I think it's not in people's best
interests not our customers best
interest to pay an AUM fee yeah how do
you reach new potential customers on
that seems very Niche Word of Mouth
correct I mean so right now right now
Twitter has been ironically enough like
where we got most of yeah because I've
been sharing a lot of personal finance
you know content up there adding about
200 subscribers a day on Twitter and a
lot of our early customers Founders
there I think our goal with this company
is to spend nothing on marketing and
honestly just do a lot of Storytelling
the content the education all of that I
think it's gonna be a big part it also
helps that you know with teachable a lot
of people in this demographic are people
I've worked with before so that that
helps a ton when it comes to our
investors we've raised money from lots
of creators for instance and again we're
not at the point of telling ours fully
going public and telling our story but
while fundraising right I'm like we
wanted to build an army of stakeholders
all these people that are invested in
our success own equity in the company at
a really good price so if and when the
company does well they own a piece of
upside as well that's interesting and
what's a day in the life for you look
like right now running this company so
right now we have an office I love
working in person right like we have to
work remotely towards the end that
teachable and I hated it I like the idea
of spending my life on zoom on a video
chat it's and if anyone's listening and
does that I'm sorry it's just not for me
I love the energy of people so I go into
the off like my days are pretty simple I
wake up I work out I go to the office
just hang out there until like six or
seven PM go do evening stuff typically
and evening stuff evening stuff what's
evening stuff you make stuff at me look
or in New York city so uh it's anything
from like dinners or going out right
pretty social so I probably end up I
would say doing stuff you know five or
six nights a week maybe one night a week
wow yeah yeah what time you wake up
seven seven yeah still very structured
yeah it's pretty structured I mean I'm
not going out till 2 A.M and stuff
that's a lot of freedom man yeah yeah
that sounds like the life right there I
love the idea of going into an office I
recently got a wework membership you did
yeah I'm going to Weaver what it's crazy
for my productivity yeah and especially
since I've been traveling at least
recently like I was in Austin like a
week ago and now I'm here in New York
then we're going to probably be
traveling more this year I figured
wework was probably we go every day uh
in Vegas yeah like the thing is even
though there was a wee work oh there are
a couple yeah I literally like I'll wake
up and I'm so excited to go to the
office like I throw in my backpack
there's something maybe it's because
it's new yeah 100 and I do think for a
lot of people like if you find yourself
in a rut it has to do with changing the
environment that you're in or just
keeping things dynamic because it's so
easy to fall into a rut and it's so hard
to get out of one and to see that there
is like light at the adaptation changes
yeah so the thing I'm trying to do a lot
of people love doing work in work out of
the office three days a week when I'm in
New York I want to work in the office
every day but what we're trying to see
is can we do something like we're
working in person for six weeks then two
weeks remote which will at least for me
like I also want the opportunity to work
in different places so um right yeah
it's work in New York every day six
weeks the next two weeks are kind of
remote and then people travel somewhere
yeah exactly actually extremely ideal
you should consider trying out we were I
mean you probably would hate it but you
should come with me sometime I would
take you until we were not interested
they have kombucha Taps so you can get
like unlimited people chop the beer on
top right after getting anything I
didn't know they had beer when we we
worked at the wework we worked at the
original wework which was uh the one in
Chelsea and it was crazy Not only would
that have beer on top they had red wine
on tap they would have cocktail hour at
3 P.M to come and I'm like don't get my
employees drunk at three in the hour
they once had mimosas on a Monday
morning and I'm like I feel like that's
like exactly
Fitness those were those were the crazy
those are the crazy reworkers those are
the years of like summer camp and like
yeah and I was like that when Adam
Newman yeah it was like and I was like I
was so annoyed I was like don't get my
team drunk on a Monday morning we have
so much to do it's fun though they have
like everything that you need so much
seating fast Wi-Fi you have to pay for
the beer and stuff like that no it's
literally yeah you walk in yeah right
you go to whatever floor it's usually a
big building with three floors and then
you just clock in and then you go
straight to the coffee of the espresso
machines or they have these tabs they
have like unlimited Seltzer like
sparkling water like not the alcohol
type kombucha Nitro cold brew coffee
everything now I heard wework was losing
a lot of money yeah and then that's why
there's no beer on top right so they cut
the beer and now they're profitable
there's some of my problems they're
working on it but at least what I found
is for me to go to the office every day
I need to have a team there like on
Friday like no one came in because like
a couple people traveling couple people
are working from home then I'm like what
am I doing here so for me going into the
office only sticks as a habit when I
have a team going in by myself I always
do it I do it for a few days few weeks
and I eventually fall out of it but
having a team working every day is
really nice what do you think of the
current work from home environment it's
not for me I think there's work from
home can work there's some kind of
workers that are very good at working
from home there's also a lot of people
that don't do much
um so I think again it's not for me and
it's it's a thing seeing those and the
trend is here to stay especially for
people that are older with kids and all
of that a lot of people don't want to go
back what do you think is going to
happen to a lot of the the big Tech it
seems like there's a divide between like
the best Engineers want to work from
home and the best companies want people
to go in who do you think is going to
give first I think you're going to be
able to choose your flavor right I think
different companies will have completely
different cultures and you can find
something that works for you for us
requiring the office has been 90 of
people don't want to work with us and
that's been great because the people
that do want to go to an office every
day it's a very specific type of person
and they're an amazing culture fit so I
actually like like running a company in
person when no one else is doing that I
think it's the same thing I think some
people say the best engine just want to
work from home and I think that's untrue
I think some of the best Engineers want
to work from home some of the best
Engineers want to go into the office and
I think that's totally cool and I think
companies will just evolve to do
different things kind of like what Elon
did with Twitter like as soon as he went
there he was like yeah we're not having
any remote employees you know if you
want to be remote you're going to have
to send like me a personal application
for that and then so many people quit
but the people that did end up staying
like they're still perfectly functional
yeah exactly with 10 of the employees
and for me what it comes down to is my
life is more valuable building something
in person like like forget the
productivity part of it like it's just
like the sense of camaraderie of like
building something together is so much
better in person like the problem with
remote work is it feels transactional
like work inherently is transactional
you get paid to perform a service but
with remote work it really reinforces
just how transactional that whole thing
is
um but when you're in person just you
actually build relationships and that's
special and you don't want to keep that
what about in terms of productivity do
you find there to be a difference
between the two or do you feel like the
benefits are beyond that I think I'm
sure productivity varies person to
person like for my job in person is
great because I'm not coding for long
periods of time but I can totally see if
your job requires intense amounts of
concentration how it's not great but for
my work which is very interrupted driven
right which means I have a meeting
you're meeting there in person is great
because I it doesn't bother me but for
some Engineers I get why once in a while
you know they want to work from home or
all of that yeah I think it's fully
based on the role what do you do when
you ever find that maybe you don't have
the motivation or you just feel a little
burnt out do you have a system to deal
with that or you just push through uh
for me I find burnout to be when I'm
doing things and not getting the results
typically versus just quantity of work
uh but I'm trying to think I mean I
haven't felt that way with this company
since it's been pretty new but typically
for me I mean you could call this
running away but just like traveling
like changing my environment is like
something very good even for a weekend
like it's just like book a flight
somewhere get out like just just go to a
brand new place and typically I find
that recharges me any desire to uh have
a family settle down yeah I mean
intellectually yes yeah uh yeah I do I
mean you know it's something that again
living in New York I think it's it's
very easy to get track you know track uh
trapped in a bit of a Peter Pan syndrome
where it's easy easy to not grow up and
I definitely feel feel that a little bit
but yeah I'm 33 now and you know at some
point I think that'd be that'd be that'd
be good yeah I'll be 33 in uh uh what's
two months yeah two months three months
it's crazy crazy and I know you were so
young yeah you guys are still so what am
I doing man yeah yeah geez yeah what's
something that you wish you knew
earlier that you felt would have would
have helped you out starting or creating
or running a business I mean I think the
idea that I got eventually but the fact
that everyone is Faking it like I used
to when I was starting a business to
think that all these people had you know
knew so much more than me and
and I realize that's that's not really
true everyone really has been is winging
it and this time for instance when I'm
building a company I'm a lot more
confident in trusting my own choices and
my own beliefs and yeah I wish it's
something I'd internalize a little bit
sooner since I spent so much time in my
last company trying to do what I thought
good CEOs do trying to do what I thought
good managers do versus what is it that
works for me as a manager as a CEO as a
leader who did you look to though just
to make sure that was correct or do you
just sometimes do what you think is best
and see what happens I think at this
point like Running Company for seven
years and now this and also investing in
over 100 companies it's enough to start
seeing the patterns
um but at the time so now I think it's
just I've done enough stuff that you see
how certain things play out over a long
enough period of time but at the time it
was very helpful to talk to a lot of my
investors it was you know I raised money
from a lot of people there were other
Founders it was very helpful to balance
stuff off of them but at this point I
mean I'm 33 but I've been involved in
text and and I was 19 years old I feel
feel like grizzled veteran
um but yeah yeah where are you investing
now are you mostly into startups or do
you put money on the side and say like
you know I'm doing index funds and real
estate so my overall strategy
um which I think can be used by a lot of
people is uh I barbelled it where I put
half of it roughly tracks the s p
um and that is my money that I kind of
never want to touch that's like
generational wealth that's the money my
kids and my kids kids and whatever we'll
have the other half I'm having a blast
with
um that is me like doing the stuff I
want and 50 50 is I mean I would not
recommend a 50 50 allocation to most
people it works for me because the the
50 in the market is enough for other
people maybe a different percentage but
and the 50 I'm investing I would say the
majority of it is in startups because
that's the world I know I have a little
bit in individual stocks which have done
terribly since last year and have lost a
lot of confidence there uh but yeah but
mostly in Tech startups where a lot of
it is a tied up in my own funds and then
some other friends funds and yeah it's
just a world I know very well and what
do you look for in a successful startup
investment what is it is it just a
someone told me that it's really just a
a investment in the person yep it's
about on the founder and how do you tell
a good founder for me typically a good
founder
um
they have a bit of a chip on their
shoulder like they really want to prove
a point
uh they move fast like scary fast like
you know it's very interesting when you
meet someone then you meet them a second
time and you're trying to think of how
much they accomplished in the interim uh
the third is their charismatic and
charismatic doesn't mean like
superficially charismatic but as a
Founder you have to continually convince
people to do things people to join your
company people to invest in you people
to buy your product so that that
combination you know I think chip on
their shoulder charismatic moves really
fast
um I think those are Hallmarks of of a
good founder what about the business
itself or is that secondary to the
person can a good person make any
business do well a good person who wants
it badly enough will be able to either
because the thing is the company you
invest in is very rarely what the
company stays business models change so
much so if someone has a bad idea or
idea that I think is all right but
they're thinking about it the right way
AKA like you know they're fully aligned
on building a venture-sized company it
could still totally work
I want to know about the 50 of the money
that you have that you're just planning
on having a blast with I mean by blast I
mean I mean investing in Higher One
glasses it's not that fun it's just like
I didn't think like we're talking like
clubs
you know I mean I mean My Lifestyle I
can like literally live the life I want
and travel and all it's like none of I
don't have like like I'm not flying
private I fly business class but even
that you know I do through points my
inherent lifestyle is actually like like
I buy everything I want and it's not a
very expensive lifestyle I just don't
have super expensive Pace Yeah Tim
Ferriss in the four hour work week did a
really good breakdown of like if if you
want the perfect life add up how much
it's going to cost every month and
chances are it's a lot less than you
would expect for like a really
incredible like baller lifestyle like
you want to drive a exotic car 2500 a
month yeah three grand a month see I
personally would love to do that but at
the same time I feel like there are way
too many moving pieces in my future it's
like okay like what is what would my
wife want well my kids want you know
what I mean so it's like wouldn't really
work for me at this time but I feel like
you know maybe
it's also so much easier without
dependence yeah right now independence
and I think I live the life I want I
travel I think like my entire lifestyle
is like it's maybe 10 grand a month
which I mean it's a lot but it's stuck
that much and I can do everything with
that jack it sounds like you're living a
life for somebody who doesn't exist yet
so no no no I'm being serious what does
that mean I don't understand
no no that means you're like living a
life like you're not living your life
now but you're trying to live it in the
future if that's what you're worried
about
that sounds very Alex hormozi-esque
coming from you Alex yeah I'm a big big
philosopher so you're saying well what
are you saying exactly so I'm saying
like don't don't sabotage yourself to
the point where it definitely hinders
what you want you know wife and kids and
a family
um but don't worry about that
necessarily now 100 because you're not
going to go out and get those
experiences good point I actually like
the point a lot yeah I agree with that I
appreciate that yeah it's hard to like
to I know I've made a good point no I
think that was a great point because I'm
always acknowledging I'm kidding I'm
always acknowledging like what I I think
my future self would want but the thing
is I always tell other people this it's
like it's generally don't spend too much
time planning what the right you want
the rest of your life to look like
because chances are it's like
something's gonna happen and there's
just gonna be like a wild turkeys set
yourself up in a position to embrace
Serendipity and everyone Point that's
wow that's a quote right there that is a
quote huh was that your quote or did you
I mean yeah uh but again I don't think
it's a particularly unique or novel
thought but yeah I think I think the
idea that you want to set yourself up to
embrace Serendipity like for me that's
why long-term travel was very helpful in
terms of yeah you just realize you can
when you're traveling a lot especially
through countries that are not super
organized and stuff you realize there's
only so much you can ever control and
you truly get good at going with the
flow
um yeah so I was all very grateful for
the time I spent in between you know
teachable and and starting this just to
spend some time you know traveling and
hanging out how'd that change your
philosophies on things
it sounded like you didn't really do
much before you know selling and then
you had the time I would travel before
selling but I would travel like the way
an average American person does which is
like you take a long weekend you stitch
together two days and you go on like an
overly ambitious five-day trip which is
very different from like last year I
left New York for six months and right
and I was just like okay I'm just gonna
go to random places I went to Mexico for
a while then I got a car and I drove
around like the Balkan countries like
former Yugoslavia for like almost two
months and just Embrace these
experiences but it was really cool I
mean I think one of the things I
realized is
like people around the world like I was
at a surf camp in Brazil and everyone
around me there was just so happy every
single day like the surf instructed the
people around there and then I compared
them to like my friends in New York who
are like smart successful people running
through businesses who are like sad and
like you know like feel strung out and
and you just look around and you realize
that
like we spend so much time in our lives
seeking like the I don't know like
success or work or all of that with this
idea of like at some Future Point
whether it's when you're retired or
whatever that you'll actually be able to
enjoy everything
um so yeah I just took some time off and
I'm like what are all the things I would
do if I was retired let me just do them
now and see you know what it is that
actually brings value to my life and if
you could distill that into a few things
what would you say those are for me it
was very simple I like spending time
outside every single day like getting
sunlight every single day is super
important to like moving my body I'm a
crazy person I walk 20 000 steps a day
and have episode started traveling so
that stuck with me yeah I do my calls
and I walk I walk how do you like how do
you get those steps you just go for
walks
uh no very little treadmill I yeah I do
any meetings I have that are one-on-one
or phone calls I do walking meetings I
love that yeah I don't do I like that we
Jack and I used to go for a run yeah and
we come up with some of our best idea is
going for all right I I also can only
think in motion I can't think when I'm
like sitting at a desk there was a study
that was actually done that proved that
is if you're if your body is physically
moving forward like you're taking steps
that way like your brain will work at a
higher efficiency I need to Pace
um the third thing third thing was
meaningful social relationships like
again it's not about
um quantity but quality of relationships
and the fourth thing was work where I
felt like the work had purpose and that
was what was missing until I started
this company I felt like when I was
traveling I had three out of the four
um but the work with the work with
purpose was missing but yeah I realized
after all all that time only these four
very very simple things are the only
things that meaningfully move the dial
on what it is that like gives me a sense
of fulfillment everything else is noise
so how do you find the time to balance
between your work right now and
traveling
uh trying to find the right balance but
again as I said a lot of companies will
say you got to come into the office two
or three times a week what we're trying
to see is if we can do six seven weeks
at the office then a week or two where
people can work from anywhere so trying
to find the right balance we're also
doing team Retreats we're taking the
entire team to Mexico City trying to see
how we can you know build that a little
bit into our culture I love that six
weeks on two weeks like kind of like
travel working yep I definitely feel
like I can Implement that right now yep
that would be what would you what would
you think about it you'd be fine with a
gram six weeks where we just like
grinding well we have just it's the last
minute guests that make it difficult if
I go east though I can make it back
because the time difference I would say
as long as we never have guests that are
booked out usually more than 24 hours in
advance I can make that easy yeah I
would say I don't care as long as long
as you can make it as long as you could
make it back for a guest
uh within probably 36 hours because we
never have anywhere that's like hey I'm
only here for the day and if we do right
we got you know Alex and I will take
care of it for you cool we'll cut you
out of that one yeah beautiful yeah this
right here I notice you guys have a
great bookshelf or you have a great
bookshelf you do a lot of reading yeah
I've been uh reading a lot first when I
was very young and then there was like a
dark period of seven or eight years but
then for the last five six years I've
been reading a lot again
um it's it sounds very silly but five
years ago I created a spreadsheet and
every time I finished a book I put it in
the spreadsheet so now I have this
record of every book I've read in the
last five years and but that mechanic
made me read much more since it gave me
this little little sense of completion
um so I gamified it and yeah I ended up
reading a lot more you know I did the
same thing but with gambling
[Laughter]
yeah I made a spreadsheet to track my
wins and losses and uh I told myself I
think I started with 500 bucks and I
said when this is all gone I'm never
gambling again and just to you don't
know me but just to give you a frame of
reference I don't go out and gamble but
it's like more like oh friends are
coming over and no because I wanted to
be like all right I want to gamble
500 bucks in my life and then once
that's gone yeah it's gone and uh no
once it's gone you'll be like well I can
always make it back so we're still up
right now so we're up about uh about
twenty eight hundred bucks oh wow for
Alex it's investing yeah
and so Alice wins like every time sports
betting or no it's literally just either
blackjack or mathematics there yeah 100
we went and played roulette Alex and I
he put in five dollars and at its high
it was at like 250. like you do realize
in what even if you do a one to one that
five dollars yeah yeah and he was at 255
I don't recommend anybody do that like
this is literally just like that's my
YOLO yeah it's only gambling if you lose
exactly exactly
I'm also this is uh off topic but uh I
love building stuff how much did did
these shelves cost you to put in because
they're they're they're awesome they're
really cool uh it was I think it was
about ten thousand dollars
um but they're fully measured to yeah
there's a ladder over there oh with the
ladder that's cool I like the ladder
yeah so so you said you read 50 books a
year I aim for 50 books a year I was at
41 last year this year we're off to a
good start we're at nine already and
it's pretty early in the year
um but yeah I I read every almost every
night it's part of the part of the daily
routine for how long it depends could be
five minutes if I'm super sleepy if it
could be two hours if I'm super into the
book I'm reading so you do it in bed
yeah and and while traveling traveling
like planes and trains all that and how
important do you think it is to be a
reader because I know from some people I
I very much respect they always say like
okay like honestly reading books is
unlike any other place like yep way that
you could educate yourself I think that
it's it's extremely beneficial what do
you think I think reading makes you a
more interesting person I don't think
you need to read to be successful at
business and in fact like as someone who
likes reading I think too many people
spend their time trying to read all the
business books and they don't actually
end up reading like literature or
fiction or other stuff so what I try to
do is I try and balance it all right yes
I'll read some books that are helpful or
can you know are like the startup books
and stuff but I think too many people
are very one-dimensional in their
reading they read just to get an edge
while I think it's important to read so
you learn to love to read you find
authors you love to read and it becomes
a thing you do to enjoy I think it makes
you more well-rounded and interesting
person so
um I think reading makes your life
better and you should find books you
love to read what are your favorite
books so my favorite like some authors I
read everything by murakami uh last year
I found this author ishiguro
um probably mispronouncing his name
another Japanese author read everything
by him so what I'll do is I like find an
author and then like write like
something then you know read everything
by them I think when I got into reading
really like Hemingway Bukowski like sort
of some of the classics over there
um but yeah I try to be pretty diverse
in in the stuff I read so I would say I
read like half fiction half non-fiction
all over the place you watch YouTube
videos or Netflix or something or is
your entertainment very little I mean I
watched I watched a little bit of TV uh
not that much probably more Sports than
then then traditional TV but yeah
interesting so basically you just swap
out what other 33 year olds would be
doing on like Tick Tock and YouTube
shorts where they don't retain any
knowledge I know I do a little bit I
mean I've definitely like opened Tick
Tock and been like where have the last
two hours of my life gone I mean I'm not
I've not not had that experience but
yeah I do try and limit that I love your
passion for reading do you think that
there's a difference between reading and
audiobooks or do you think that I can't
do audiobooks I literally cannot do
audiobooks my brain is just like in a
different world like for a while I'm
like oh when I'm at the gym let me
listen to audiobooks but I just Spotify
like yeah
like music Spotify wow yeah for me I
just do audio books or if I could find
it on YouTube I'll just download it on
YouTube and listen to it 2x speed
interesting my brain can't keep up I
just zone out I think all this stuff and
then like what were they saying for the
last two minutes yeah I'm with you on
that because the thing is if you're if
you're audio booking that means you're
probably doing something else hence why
you're audio booking in the first place
like you're at the gym so you're working
out or you're driving so I'm focusing on
the road but I usually just zone out and
figure you know focus on the actual
attack is that zoning out by the way is
very helpful a lot of my ideas come in
that period of when I'm walking listen
to music and zoning out so zoning out is
actually like a good thing so yeah
audiobooks are not for me what's your
favorite book over here
have to pick a single one yeah
I really enjoyed there's a book there by
girl never let me go it was it's a
little black mirror-esque and that was
really good but pick one that I read
recently and so you got to fill out
these tops shelves and yeah there is
there's a long way to go I've been I
think I probably I buy a lot of books
probably by like I would say on average
20 books a month and it's still no way
books are so cheap relative to what
value you can get out of it a ten dollar
book can give you an amazing five six
hours and like lessons you retain for so
long five okay five six hours to read a
book is uh it's pretty fast there's a
big very I mean yeah yeah like I mean I
would say books books can take anywhere
from three to Thirty you know like yeah
but I would say five six is probably
median hmm you fast reader I'm a fast
reader yeah yeah yeah I remember books
when I was at school take me like weeks
to read the thing like a month to read a
book yeah it'd be so bad with it have
you wanted to write a book I feel like
you would do a great job I do want to
write a book but I want to write a book
as in for the art of writing right I
don't want to write a book in the way
that well actually I do want to like
there's writing a book to use as a
marketing funnel and just writing a book
to like like the art of it both are
probably things I would want to do for
different purposes but yeah part of me
my like dream like in a different life
is to sit somewhere and try and write
fiction I think it's gonna be super cool
that's something I just do for fun you
know it's not not for the business of it
but I think it'd be really fun that's
interesting for some reason I imagine
you writing a book on like startups like
uh Alex yeah
I mean there's a world I would write a
book on Personal Finance but that would
be for be related to work that wouldn't
be purely for passion but I could see
that as well but the art of writing
itself is interesting to me and I you
know I would probably write a terrible
novel at some point in my life So
eventually when you do let's say well I
shouldn't assume that you're going to
sell whatever company you're working on
right now but I don't want to we want to
our goal the company that I'm super
inspired and motivated by
um is Charles Schwab because they're the
last sort of big company to come into
the space they were founded in 1975
they're now with 150 billion dollars and
they change an entire generation's
relationship with their money they
became a trusted brand so our goal is to
build something of Charles Schwab's side
is an impact so I thought Schwab was a
lot older nope they're they they're like
all the other banks are like 150 years
old Schwab 1975 they're the young kid on
the Block and what would you do let's
just say if you were no longer
affiliated with this business
um again like go back like just think
about one of the things that make me
happy go back to those four things right
like continue like Define meaning in
like all the you know traveling spending
time uh with my family continuing to
just find ways of becoming better it was
very clear early on that pure Leisure is
not that fun right like at no point like
it's pure leisure not that far if that
fun for three days but I've I feel like
I could pick any activity it could be I
don't know it could be surfing it could
be a sport and get super super
obsessively deep about it
um I definitely have that tendency like
last summer I joined a tennis league and
I haven't played tennis in a while and I
wasn't even very good but then I got
pretty good over the summer so I can you
know pick anything and obsess over it so
I think that's that's quite possible so
anything you found that's not worth the
experience uh of s cargo
uh uh like it's okay like a thing that I
think is overrated like are a lot of
like very very nice restaurants like I
like in Mexico City I went to like some
of the nicest restaurants and a few
times after we went to taquerias right
after and like enjoyed the food at
Taqueria as much more
um so yeah I think I think when it comes
to like luxury experiences I think so
many of them are so overrated and not
sort of worth the price to pay for them
I agree with that 100 people made fun of
me for this uh you know who exactly who
you are I say as soon as like a meal
eclipses like the 20 range as long as it
goes above that I honestly think the
food tastes worse I feel like there's
something about that 10 to 20 range of
food that's just like the best I feel
like that gets you 80. partly orders now
over twenty dollars not New York New
York double double steak Bowl not even
no block is now 20 and 40 cents so they
charge for double steak now 20.40
my friend got the same bowl with Wok 23
or 24. that's stupid so yeah 20 gets you
nothing okay well yeah so adjust it for
the subway
I don't like the food there in general
but I do like that price I think that in
that price range if you just go to like
a random place in this corner you know
like they're gonna have good food if you
get like a 40 to 50 Burger I honestly
think it just starts tasting weird like
the Burgers start getting tall no one
wants a diet burger and forty dollars
cool down I hate doing that because
then you ruin like all the art that went
into like building out exactly but you
also like have to basically you get
lockjaw when you're trying to take your
first bite of it you know it doesn't fit
that's true yeah and it all ends up
coming out the back anyway
somehow the fun just disappeared it's
almost weird no I'm usually left with
like too much fun like mine at the very
end is like this much meat really that
much fun I do yeah I mean the one thing
I do miss by the west coast is in and
out so I am jealous that you have that I
mean and that's very good yeah yeah and
you can you can specify the ratio like I
typically get a four by three four meat
three cheese it's great
it's probably still like seven dollars
why do you not like just make it happen
yeah no I should consider that yeah yeah
you know what I want to ask this last
question what's your brother up to oh
that's a great question my brother my
brother's chilling he's uh he went to he
just graduated business school from
McGill uh he's now living in Toronto and
working in Tech and yeah that's the
other thing he and I have gotten to
spend and so much more time together
um over the last few years since he
moved back to the side of the world
um but yeah he's great is there ever
like a rivalry between you guys now I
don't think so I think like again we our
relationship has grown so much and like
I still I still talk my entire family so
often I talk to my parents almost every
single day I talk to my brother almost
weekly like we're we're very very close
as a family and yeah it means a lot
that's cool
well thank you so much I really
appreciate it a great episode nice
meeting you thank you for hosting us yes
beautiful home oh also we got a free
stock and also you can have me on
Instagram
will be down below in the description
your your links and everything thank you
guys for tuning in and thank you next
time
I love that behind the scenes
can you flip your mic on YouTube gram
can you flip your mic oh it's a face the
other way yeah got it bigger I'm sure
all right here you go so see how the
glue goes this way okay
now flip Andrew put this at the end okay
okay
no you have Road Wireless goes there the
same thing yeah there you go oh look
there you look great yes
thank you